mmm dink dink dink dink dink dink
welcome back to the gingely podcast tick
to bring my phone in here what is going
on we just recorded in intro realize you
weren't recording we're recovering from
sickness hello how are you I just read a
we did the first like three minutes and
I looked at Jen I was like that didn't
record nothing
oh why am I even here
we need a new audio/video guy I'm tired
no we were talking about how marvels is
sitting like hot dog style on this
hamburger style
he's hitting hamburger style but it's a
hot dog shaped bed so he looks like a
taco oh my okay sprinkle some cilantro
[Music]
some hot sauce table anyway welcome to
the Julian podcast this episode is
brought to you by post mates your
favorite restaurants delivered to your
house or place of work or wherever
honestly with post mates it's a great
app that we use all the time and you get
a hundred dollars of free delivery
credits when you use cogent and Julian
and download the post mates app right
now do it go ahead you don't believe
this
try it go ahead post mates is wonderful
we love them use them all time also a
farmer's dog and incredible
farm-to-table service that customizes
human grade board certified that
approved food for your pets specifically
formulated for your pets they make
custom meal plans it's incredible our
dogs love it
start treating your dogs with farmers
dog they will love it go to the farmer's
dog comm / channel you get 50% off your
first two weeks and everyone's happy
that's it just do it and everyone's
happy you know is everything good are we
I think so I think we're finally
regarding Jesus welcome back we feels
like it's been eight years
and how does in 84 years oh it's been
like a week and a half since we were
last in here recording but first things
first okay first things first happy and
Congrats 20 million subscribers
you're insane you're owning that is such
a crazy number and you hit it oh can we
get a round of applause for Jenna
applause please this is what we used to
do in school we round of applause
because it's around you yeah Congrats
it's really nice that anybody gives the
[ __ ] like who cares like I understand
what no I I would care like you know
what I mean like oh it's really cool
that's exciting but it's I don't
understand why anyone else really
[ __ ] cares who cares but thank you I
really appreciate the nice things that
people have said to me it happened last
night
I think it did yeah I was laying in bed
someone had tweeted at me already like
you guys just start are nice people
someone was like you hit 20 million it
was like I don't even know thank you
it's really nice of you what the hell
people find a lot of pride in supporting
a person that they see is a genuine and
real person with you know down to earth
thank you I'm a grown woman all I can do
it's incredible it's crazy I mean we we
were at home most of our time making
videos and whatnot and then a number
like 20 million gets brought up and
you're just like what where did that
come from
but I just like live here and do
whatever I want what do you mean that's
my favorite voice Chris Mel burger voice
I know you love doing that voice how
does it feel do you feel different yeah
I feel totally different it feels like I
don't you turned 20 million oh thanks
happy birthday oh I'm a dinosaur that's
such a stupid number so they give the
diamond one away for ten million right
oh yes all right so they sent you
another one
no no and we hit it twice I don't think
you get anything for twenty million as
far as I know you'll get a customized
PewDiePie one when you hit 50 and then
an even more customized PewDiePie one
when you hit a hundred you got a fifty
one two yeah oh I thought really got a
hundred one no I think you got a fifty
one hmm well I mean that's just an
insane you know what's crazy is like um
you you've hit all of these crazy
numbers like
even just by the million right 1918 1710
like all these numbers that you've hit
they've always seemed at least to me
crazy yeah it is crazy but 20 million is
definitely the craziest even crazier
than 19 million bill it sounds
completely made-up it doesn't sound real
completely yeah but it's the culmination
of a lot of years of just keeping your
[ __ ] head down and not stopping yeah
and you've obviously been doing it for
over ten years and you've evolved as a
person and your contents of all but the
thing that's remained the same is like
I'm still doing my job I'm still doing
this and here you are 20 million yeah I
mean I do very much see it as like my
job you know it doesn't define me which
then helps look with my mindset to like
you know you go live your life that's
that's your job sometimes I find it
embarrassing like I don't you know it
just is what it is just what I do for a
living and it's just really cool but
like the the cool part of it it's like
all the funny people that you meet and
interact with on a daily basis like that
part's very fun and exciting but
20,000,000 funny people yeah it's
probably 19 million funny like 1 million
unfunny Wow got to be real with y'all
but yeah I don't know it sounds
completely made-up and ridiculous it's
amazing to me that anyone is still
subscribing to my channel at this point
like going to your channel clicking
subscribe yeah like I figured years and
years ago I was like anybody that's
gonna subscribe man they've already
subscribed that's it it's the growth is
over it's only unsubscribing from here
people don't unsubscribe very much I
feel like yes they do not to you you hit
20 million people unsubscribe for me all
the time I'm sure yeah but just have a
much much more insignificant rate than
they do subscribing or at least new
viewers come but yeah I mean damn dude
[ __ ] that's cool so you have anything
cool planned can you tell us where
you're gonna keep it a secret till you
release the video well I mean it I think
some people know I was well let me know
I guess if it's something you'd want to
see I was like I kind of just want to
take a nap 420 million subscribers like
I feel like there's a lack
Knapp content I also I know on Twitch
you can't like livestream yourself
sleeping yeah because they don't want
people to just turn a camera on it's a
liability when it's live yeah it's alive
ability um but I'm pretty sure that I
could just take a nap and upload it to
YouTube in its entirety without a
problem
but I was just thinking you know I am
very tired in a long time
well yeah and you know in sport
psychology they always say ten years ten
thousand hours is what makes you a
million is what makes you a professional
at something I started my first youtube
channel in 2007 but it contained my
entire last name in it my real last name
so I made the jenna Marbles channel in
2009 nine or ten you've you've just
about been doing jenna Marbles on
YouTube for ten years
yeah so I'm officially a professional
youtuber like legit yeah can you put on
your LinkedIn yeah definitely my I just
looked up my brother looked me up on
LinkedIn the other day I didn't realize
I still had one Wow he tried to link
with me don't do that see Marlon no no
Lincoln I don't want to do with linking
but I definitely think I've put in
10,000 hours into YouTube easily mm-hmm
yeah oh yeah ten times over I feel like
I may be wrong but ten years comes
slower than 10,000 hours well it depends
like in in sports right if you like
there's plenty of examples of people
that picked up a sport like when they're
18 or 19 but if you put in 10,000 hours
you can become an Olympic athlete you
know again an elite athlete not that you
will get will go yeah totally it can
come you can theoretically become a
complete professional at something no
inside it out 10,000 hours which will be
faster than 10 years but for a lot of
people to invest in something would
probably take you around 10 years yeah
so impressive I think it's interesting
that that kind of threshold of the 10
year 10,000 hour rule is happening right
when you hit 20 million pretty cool
yeah ten years I think I hit $10,000
many many years ago you know what never
gets all um you know the occasional
video coming out where this the kind of
the scope of like youtubers is discussed
of like what youtubers like now and what
they used to be like and who's still
relevant whatever and you always
inevitably come up as an example of
someone who has kind of transcended
these like boundaries in these lines of
like generations of youtubers and you've
kind of just existed through through the
through the separation of them I think
the most recent was Drew Gooden when he
was talking about the ace family and
then he brought you up and you're
talking about how you're just like
you're you and your success and your
wealth and everything does that mean in
the background why I want to embarrass
you it's your 20 million birthday party
shouts out drew by the way his contents
awesome but that is something that never
gets old for me and it does happen
recurringly and it has happened
regularly over the last however long you
know eight years that I've known you
almost and it's it's cool because it's
like it's it's just the same path and
the same attitude that you've kept
that's been just tried and true and it's
kept you going and it's it's it's just
impressive and I think a lot of people
are taking note and have taken out over
the years but 20 million and you not
stopping here baby
Thanks here we come thirty no that's
very cool so congrats it was just like
it was my goal since forever because I
do truly think that like the Internet is
the funnest the best place yeah and it
was never really my goal to transition
that into something else you know I feel
like I've tried other things but I just
want to be a person that makes internet
content and I think the last time that I
said that was when I was like watching
my old videos in that video and I just I
don't know I think that it it has the
best space for people to just do people
things like that's what I find the most
genuinely entertaining is people
themselves and
you know it's harder and harder to get
real content from people sometimes yeah
because of the way that everything just
gets so jumbled you know there's a lot
of money a lot of like people with hands
and their cookie jars and [ __ ]
shifting the way that things look and
feel and sound yeah and we're always
sort of looking for the most authentic
and real versions of people that we can
find which is why I feel like there's
been another explosion popularity of
podcasts right like 20 19 we have all
these amazing [ __ ] things right we
have [ __ ] VR like what the hell but
people still just want to listen to have
listened to other people have like real
conversations yeah where as you know I'm
sure people were like yeah podcast no
one's gonna listen to that because who
the [ __ ] wants to sit down and listen to
a conversation when I can slap on a VR
helmet go somewhere else that's also and
that's also something that you've been
kind of preaching for a while in a way
that like when you when you strip it
down to the bare bones of people and how
people want to entertain themselves it's
always been a little bit voyeuristic
were you wired all the way back to
reality TV right and like people just
want to see other people's lives and I
just want to see what other people's
lives are like yeah and you've been
saying that for a long time and it's
true because that thread of of interest
will always remain it seems like that we
don't know but it seems like that and so
you have like this explosion of this
like New Age of youtubers where there's
like they're all flaunting their wealth
and their and their cars and their
success and it's a very different vibe
of like the first wave of youtubers that
you were a part of but it's kind of come
back now and people are still interested
in finding the content that just makes
them feel like I'm watching another
person live their life right well I mean
I'm interested in all content like I
will watch people flaunt their wealth
it's sometimes very interesting to watch
good or bad yeah you know but the the
core of that is that people just want to
see what other people's lives early yeah
and that's what I've always sort of felt
in terms of like staying on YouTube and
being on YouTube and not really having
the goal of like doing something else
like
want to be an internet person you know I
do YouTube is not your trampoline to the
next thing kind of yeah like I I just
want to be an Internet person yeah you
know and if that means that my cap first
success or like money or anything like
ends wherever like that's fine cuz I get
to [ __ ] do whatever I want you're
living that's worth so much to me like
to have a voice and like sorry I'm so
like so sick by the way we're both sick
too like to have a voice and you know be
able to say whatever I want and make
whatever I want do whatever I want
whenever I want you know it's like that
to me is the best thing ever
yeah and I will say I'd be if I'm a
betting man I would be I would bet that
you wouldn't have reached 20 million in
the in the spirits and the mental health
that you have without learning that you
need to take some breaks from time to
time and that's an important lesson that
you've learned the last couple years and
a proud of you for that thank you as
someone who lives with you I'm proud of
you I'm also happy that you've learned
to self-care in that department because
I think you explained it really well and
you're in one of the recent videos where
we tried making two videos and neither
of them worked and you're like you were
talking about how you've had this kind
of way of thinking built into your brain
so like deeply you know ingrained in
there that you like if you don't make a
video one week it is the end of the
world because it's well there was a
period of time on YouTube when that was
the case for sure and I was I remember
that about you and I remember you know
seeing how intense it is sometimes when
things don't work or whatever but it's
like the show must go on and what you
talked about how I think I'm just gonna
learn to like break that train of
thought and break that way of thinking
and it's very powerful to say something
like that out loud on the internet
namely but also just to yourself yeah
when you're being honest yeah I like
talking to yourself and thinking about
you know the decisions that you need to
make on a weekly basis for your best
interest which includes work and mental
health and everything so that's one of
the things that I think is the most
important growth signs that I've seen
from you right in the last because I
mean anyone that you know does stuff on
the internet and a lot of you guys that
look
this do you know you you just sort of
like relentlessly hammer that in like
you you got to make stuff right you
can't post one thing and then wait six
months then post another thing and be
like why is no one watching my thing
hello
I posted a thing watch it no like you
have to do it on a regular basis and
there was a point in time when if you
stopped posting it was very competitive
you know there's you know people would
make a three minute long video and
that's sort of like the cap like most
hours don't yeah that was very long the
ideal length of video was about a minute
maybe a minute and a half because people
were using the internet as sort of like
quick quick fix quick laughs quick this
quick that everything needed to be very
fast and there was no like 10 minute
long videos on 20 min yeah and if it was
like ones like I don't have time to
watch this like it's people did not make
the time for the internet that they have
now yeah
whereas now we look to YouTube or I
guess you know Netflix er that's a
little different but like I want to
watch something that's 30 minutes long
or 40 minutes long or an hour long two
three four or five whatever because this
is what I'm using as my entertainment
now yeah whereas before it was like I
got you know 10 minutes on my lunch
break and I just want to watch something
funny you know I don't want to waste 10
minutes on some video of some girl
talking about her bedroom yeah you know
but if you did not post and you weren't
constantly putting things out there you
sort of just got lost in the shuffle you
know because it's all very new no one
knows who you are why do I care I don't
care and I think that that is one of the
hardest things to do as a person that
makes things on the Internet
it's just getting anybody to care like
who cares okay you know you have a short
little window of getting people to watch
it and be like I like that mm-hmm
and then in an authentic and you know
aggressive way capitalizing on that yeah
you know but I mean for years I do very
much feel like I've had that drilled
into my head that like you can't just
like not
post you know and I think a large part
of that is thanks to the people who have
supported me for so many years because
they do make me feel like if you don't
post it's okay I'm not gonna forget that
you exist you know whereas before it was
a very real fear I mean you'll get a ton
of comments that are like I didn't
realize you were still even that's a
cool testament to the fact that you're
picking up new people watching your
stuff too but yeah I mean it's it's also
like you've sort of earned your keep a
little bit right like in the beginning
you can't really afford to take any time
off and you didn't take any time off for
a lot of years but you sort of invested
in yourself and your channel and your
brand yeah and it could all [ __ ]
crumble in flames
tomorrow you never know yeah but um yeah
I really appreciate like from the bottom
of my heart the support of like we were
able to actually take a vacation are my
first vacation in 10 years and leave for
a week and not post and you guys really
made me feel like it's gonna be okay you
know it's like [ __ ] thank you oh my
god it's I mean I mean that feeling I
mean it's like incredible mm-hmm yeah um
but it's also nice to see things like
you know and Shane Dawson posts a series
and he hasn't posted on this channel in
like six months but people are waiting
and are excited for something that he's
gonna put out that he cares about like
it just it gives me hope for people that
are like making things on stop and
they're there in that world and they're
in that space and they're like I'm on
the neverending hamster wheel like when
is this ever gonna end that you know if
you build your audience and and there
are people that do actually care about
you as a person which a lot of you do
and that's really [ __ ] nice of you
thank you for that that you know it's
not just about pumping out content it's
about making things that you like and
aren't making you your quality of life
well and you know you give you give a
certain amount of years and a certain
number of hours
of yourself relentlessly to the Internet
no I don't think that you have to but a
lot of people do what I did yeah and
yeah I mean it's it is definitely a cool
thing especially like when you're a fan
of someone right like if you're if I'm a
fan of a youtuber and I see that they're
just like grinding themselves on the
bone and they're getting stressed and
their content is still coming out
regularly and they're not missing a day
but it's like you can just tell they're
like you it's just as a fan of that
person you're invested in them as a
person not it's just like an entertainer
like an actor in Hollywood you're like I
want you to be happy I don't want you to
be killing yourself to make this content
you know you don't know how your quality
of life to be good yeah I feel like that
is a viewer so much.when yeah I'm like I
said that in that video and someone like
tweets out you know that's this terrible
thing happened and I just can't post I'm
really sorry I'm like I feel really like
you a lot as the human being and I want
you to have a good time and be happy Sam
just [ __ ] post you want whatever I
mean unfortunately I don't think that
that's good advice so like grow it a lot
of you are trying to grow your YouTube
channels I don't think that post quote
posting whatever you like whenever you
like is the very good plan I do think
that there is value in creating content
on a schedule and by sort of forcing is
the bad word but like grinding and
pushing yourself to make things even
when it you like that's part of your job
yeah if you treat YouTube as a job or
any sort of content creation as a job
it's not every time you go into work no
matter what it is there's definitely
days when you feel like I'd rather be
face down into my pillow in my bed right
now right it's not that you're forcing
it but you are doing the thing that you
said that you would do on a schedule on
days even when you're not excited to do
it yeah yeah and that's nothing you're
not passionate about and don't usually
that you're just you're keeping yourself
to a schedule yeah and that's like a
level of discipline but what I'm talking
about is mainly like even looking down
the road right you're like man in five
years if I'm a youtuber right if I'm
gonna make this content and really push
myself in five years maybe I can get to
the the the place not necessarily
number-wise but the place that Shane is
or the place that Jenna is where you
like mainly Shane right like you look
you look towards the future where you
grind it out to the point where people
are invested in you they believe in you
and they stick around and you're like
okay now I want to take a month to make
a video right and then you make a video
and they don't forget about you
it's like that's just an it's an
encouraging prospect for people I feel
like it would be so not there I mean
Shane started years before me and but it
years ago that was not a thing right you
didn't post for months by it's a bye but
yeah you would see a tangible you know
effect of taking that much time off yeah
and not that it's like the same exact
thing as twitch but like I know a lot of
people that live stream on Twitch our
live stream in general it's like when
you take time off you you can tell a
tangible difference oh you know it does
hurt which is a very very different
beast oh my god that place there's a lot
of similarities is scary and art and
people are afraid to take time off yeah
definitely definitely in it yeah but
that's what I'm talking about it was
like live streaming I feel like is its
own beast and that like you do really
see a tangible difference if you take
time off YouTube was like that to a
lesser degree but it still still present
you know it's still scary and people are
afraid of that you know all those years
that you spent building up your audience
and and building up your abilities as a
person to take some time off just really
feels like I don't want to shoot myself
in my own foot first you know yeah you
know we've done own a lot of Wednesday's
- what ordered post mates Julie because
sometimes we're filming at the house and
we can't get out we're in the middle of
stuff there is no lie but get to the
grocery store we can't cook ourselves
food we're just too busy so post mates
is there for us and have been there for
us for a while guys post mates is
amazing if you're busy if you're tied up
and you need to just go on your phone
select from a menu and click what you
want and have it delivered to your house
that's what post mates is for you
download the app see what restaurants
and businesses are in your area that
have delivery and you click go and then
a post mate is just on their way to
four hours a day 365 days a year post
mates is active and operational okay so
anytime anything anywhere you can post
mate it check it out by going to the App
Store and downloading post mates we're
going to post mates comm /n and Julian
use code Jenna Julian in the app to get
the discount of $100 of free delivery
credit in your first seven days of using
the app check it out is a really
wonderful service super convenient and a
longtime supporter of us also guys
farmers dog if you want to feed your
little guys even if they're picky eaters
farmers dog is there to formulate a meal
that is perfect for them both on like a
scientific level of what they need with
nutrients but also like their flavors
and what kind of food they like to you
fill out a little bit of a profile for
your pet right online what their eating
habits are how often they eat what they
like what they don't like how much they
need to eat what their breed is what
their sizes and farmers are will help
formulate a completely customized meal
plan for that pet of yours if you have
multiple they can do multiple they do it
for three of ours and then they ship a
giant box of you know farm freeze-dried
fresh food to your house so it stays
good and you put it in your fridge and
your freezer and then you just feed them
it's so easy and they love it they like
run they're like fiends for it every day
when I feed him breakfast and dinner
they love it especially marvelous right
he used to be such a Jets yeah you
wouldn't believe how fast he runs in
time and you cut open the little pouch
it's so easy so right now go to the
farmer's dog calm slash Jenna and
Julianne get 50% off your first two week
trial of fresh healthy food with the
farmers dog and let's not only like it
thank you spawn singing sponsors I'm
honestly like in reflecting back on how
many years for my channel mmm that kind
of stuff I'm I'm surprised and
completely relieved and happy that
YouTube moved away from the like daily
vlogger schedule because I feel like
that that was a period in time in
youtube history where I really didn't
know if I was gonna make it
through that phase or if people would
still be interested in weekly content
yeah like there are a lot of people like
me that we're like alright well if this
is what YouTube wants you know people
that post everyday yep I'm not I'm not
you guy I'm not gonna [ __ ] post
everyday I think it's completely
unhealthy and not doing it and I'll be
here it was definitely a wave and it
definitely came in when it was [ __ ]
terrifying to it I was like it's not
healthy for Pete do it is bad yeah and
it was horrible because like you if you
were a vlogger and you did vlog every
day you're like okay I'm making X amount
of money if I vlogged three days a week
and I'm making double that if I vlog
every day right why would I not do this
and it was always this carrot that was
dangled and well it's always been the
case for sure but there was this period
where like you look how well you're
doing posting once a week just post
twice a week I'm like I feel like
there's a threshold though like there's
a threshing back when you started
totally like there's a threshold of when
you're when you're growing and then
people are like well if I post excellent
times and I make X then not if I post
twice that I'll make twice that yeah I
feel like your growth gets capped and
like your earnings account everything
gets capped mostly because people are
like well I like when I get this much of
you and although I want more of you over
time you know it makes sense if you post
once a week because then I'm not
completely [ __ ] I can't stand you by
like month one if someone posts every
single day and don't get me wrong there
are plenty people that so posts like
every single day that I think are
wonderful people and their audience
thinks that they're wonderful people
it's it's nothing to do with that but
like the opportunity for someone to get
completely exhausted of you from posting
every single day are pretty high it's
like I like you I live with you I see
you every day I talk to you every single
day you're one of the only people that I
[ __ ] feel that way about you know
like if I see someone every single day
chances are I'm probably just gonna get
a little bit sick of them yeah you know
but it's just
it's not personal bad people what I also
think that I just don't want to watch
anymore
well I think that wave the huge
explosion of like people vlogging every
single day mm-hmm I mean not to do the
[ __ ] obvious and what everyone
doesn't quote it but the everyday bro
like that whole phase that happened
where people like it is the grind you
post a vlog every single day and saying
that it's the grind at the same time no
but that in in like the least cringy way
that is the grind that was the grind
that was like the meta so to speak for
YouTube vloggers and it was it was scary
for me because back then you know
roughly around that I was still vlogging
and I was still doing the thing where I
was like pointing a camera myself and
making a story about my day almost every
day it gets so hard and I tried it every
day for a while and it you saw it made
me crazy and nuts and I did vlog miss a
couple years and to me nuts see I only
like vlogmas cuz I did it once a year
and I think I only did it what like
three times so here right yeah once a
year I'll vlog yeah but like even for me
who is vlogging three four times a week
throughout the year upping it to seven
just kicks your ass yeah mentally more
than anything you're like not you're not
even oh you get to like day 10 you're
like I'm not even living my life - yeah
I'm literally like wow I'm filming this
I'm thinking about when I'm gonna edit
and also film the next and what I'm
doing tomorrow and it's just like I'm an
insane person yeah nothing about this is
no I'm I'm really really glad that
YouTube whether they tangibly decided to
stop pushing channels that were posting
every single day or just audiences were
like I was interested in this for the
first couple for now not anymore I think
it was more that than anything I think
because it's just human nature to just
get sick of something if you have too
much yeah and it's nothing personal it's
never personal I applaud those people
for working so hard but like it's it's
just it's a lot from the same thing
mm-hmm you know it's like I'm sure there
are people that tune in to Jimmy Kimmel
ever sing all night solely for Jimmy
Kimmel but like it's you know seeing one
person a lot all the time yeah although
sometimes can be a positive thing and
like a constant in your life you know if
you like listened to a show every single
day part of your routine but if it's
about that person
life constantly yeah you know like a
late-night talk show right if someone
was really invested in that and they
watched it every single day I have a
tolerance for this because the subject
matter is different every single day
it's not about Jimmy Kimmel's family
every single day it's it's relevant to
what's going on in the world it changes
for guests different musical acts like
there's something different happening
every day yeah and the subject matter is
not personal about him you know he's
just the thread that's sort of running
through it but like to watch someone
else's life on a daily basis I think is
honestly too much for a lot of people
sometimes yeah and it's nothing personal
well like if you take David Oberg for
example the reason why someone could
watch david dobrik videos every single
day is because the subject matter is
different and constantly changing yeah I
mean it's a little it's a weird and it's
bad it's it's a little [ __ ] economy and
it's but it's most importantly like the
way he formulates his videos is like
entertainment first exactly if this
video is entertaining I'm gonna post it
if it's not I'm not posting it there's
never like you know he's done so many
things that no one has done right and
one of those things is making his vlogs
a certain level of energetic and
entertaining regardless of if it
involves him or his personal life right
right but it's still a vlog and it's not
that he's tricking you but it's like
you're used to the word vlog meaning
something and so then you watch his
videos and you're like this is well no
you watch it and you're like and it's
like crazy and hilarious and someone's
jumping on someone and you're like this
is this is happening yes he's just
pulling out his camera and documenting
this and in a way and in a way he is
because that that is what's happening
but he's definitely for for a lack of a
better you know phrasing he's definitely
kind of altered the way of vlog can be
and like what it means to be there's no
continuity it's just like here's a part
here's a part here's a part how much
does he post a week like three or four
times yeah I think he cut down to
something yeah yeah even David like he's
supposed to every day but you're also
like he's not making himself you know
incredibly vulnerable by showing himself
inside and out you know it's not it it
is in theory like a documentary of
David's
for many years he's been posed here but
it's not like as personal sometimes as a
vlog can be which is gnarly but it yeah
but it does make it so that he can
continue on doing that on a more regular
basis without feeling so like you know
the way that a vlog makes you feel
sometimes yeah for sure I mean and like
having been there like that's it that's
kind of a scary place to be sometimes
when you feel like you're you're giving
too much of yourself
and then you start to feel like [ __ ]
like I need to just like draw a line
somewhere
you know like keep my personal [ __ ] to
myself and I think a lot of loggers go
through that or whatever but yeah I mean
he's he's a really interesting like
example of like someone who's because
the format is not a traditional blog
know and he's largely like kind of
coined that format for a long time now
and it's crazy
he's [ __ ] exhausted anyways this was
a really long conversation to get to the
plants I might just take a nap 420
million subscribers and am i filming it
no I'm just gonna put a camera on a
tripod I honestly I feel like if I tried
to sit down and film a nap like member
years ago I'd periscoped an apple I
remember that I was [ __ ] great
but the dogs were running all over me
the entire time I feel like if I tried
to take because I don't really nap
during the day but if I tried to take a
nap the dogs would just walk on me bark
dig in my [ __ ] try and get in my
blanket like Kermit does Kermit would
just be a dick the whole time I could
remove him well long story short
congrats on 20mil thank you do you think
I should take a nap 420 million I think
people are expecting it you mentioned it
a long time ago I think you'd be a
disappointment if you didn't I think you
least need to try it and if it doesn't
work you can explain it didn't work but
so I posted and then delete it no like
no no no I don't mean try posting I mean
try filming it oh I see you know and
then if it comes out like you taking a
nap with it looks like a nap then yeah
poster so it'll be like you know a 20 or
30 minute video but most of it will just
be me napping watch a trend no
I'm just saying watch it we'll know
YouTube would never because they don't
want to promote sleeping content
although I feel like there should be
more sleeping content so much different
than this it's like for for the reason
twitch saying you can't sleep on stream
is like a safety thing no I know but
they also don't want people to be like
earning revenue by being alive so then
they're just live 24/7 and through
sleeping and everything no I think it's
I don't think it's about revenue I think
it's way more a liability yeah for sure
from twitch because it's like they draw
that line hard when it comes to passing
out from drinking or sleeping or
anything like that that's a liability
right because then if anything horrible
happens right it's they were on Twitch
and twitch was allowing them to monetize
that or something so that's definitely
where I think it comes from but I don't
think it's the same at all on YouTube I
think it's completely apples and oranges
so try it I don't know we could get we
could do we could even get a couple
angles you know No oh sorry don't don't
let me get involved I'm gonna make it
all messy okay okay one angle no movie
two lenses know where we get the audio
from overhead mic overhead mic oh my god
how about we just here's what we'll do
we'll lean your iPhone up against the
wall front camera record honestly shitty
it's awesome that's what I would do
speaking of iPhone camera can we
celebrate 20 million by getting you a
new [ __ ] iPhone goddammit no no you
said you wanted one no I said I was
thinking about oh oh my battery dies if
I wake up at like 9:00 my bad really be
dead by 11 a.m. you need she has iPhone
7 y'all get a new bring it up
yeah well it's it's it's it's an ugly
thing so well you know my phone's even
like two three years old now and it's
[ __ ] showing signs like you need a
new phone sometimes okay sometimes I'll
be like hey babe can you take a picture
me and I'm looking at this thing and I'm
like what the hell kind of camera is on
this this looks so bad and then you'll
try to like
wipe off the lens and you're like okay
here then it's still bad I don't even
like really take pictures so like that's
why yeah but then why do I need that
spider phone with spider eyes you don't
a spider eyes one there's ones with two
lenses like this just simple ones like
this it's good I don't work for Apple I
promise don't take pictures have you
noticed I don't post on the Instagram
you do Instagram stories of the dogs and
me often because we are yeah okay yeah
yeah but I just take screenshots of my
video game so that I can you know fix my
build didn't do miss those okay you
don't need to get all nerdy on us we're
just congratulating Evert why I didn't I
didn't I have to go soon because I have
a progression group to get to okay we're
sick it's called the Elder Scrolls
online it's a really good video game
please don't worry eyes at me I have a
progression group that I have to get to
I know we went to the ER this week that
was fun yeah cuz we were sick you got
sick from - it's gone we got really sick
from twitchcon and I'm still we're both
still kind of at the tail end of our
colds or whatever the [ __ ] I had a
pretty bad fever
Julie's temperature it was like bob was
playing the oldest girls online I took a
break to cook up children some medicine
and take his temperature and his
temperature was 104.3 so I was like we
should probably go to the ER because my
temperature was my FM 104.3 okay no put
that sentence back in your mouth 104.3
my offense go to the ER yeah I was I
went to sleep I went to take a nap at
like 7 p.m. and I was 102 then I went to
sleep woke up and I started making
noises like I was dying and gentlemen
are you okay and she came in took my
temper I was 104.3 and mine was 102 at
that point like I didn't feel good
either and I just never got to the point
that you did and so we took Jillian to
the ER and they basically treated him as
if he had the flu so they gave him an IV
there was like some steroids that
there's still tape on my arm yeah
steroids and um what else
so friend fluid technology yes he was so
nauseous
oh god that's Oh friend it's quite the
godsend but yeah they they juiced me up
good like a juice box I was a human
juice box yeah but I had a fever and I
was sitting there like in the ER like
not getting any treatment not because I
didn't really need it and feel like and
so I've just been sort of kicking it out
of my system yeah but um yeah we were
there for like three hours and someone
was in there coming off of drugs
screaming screaming help me for two
hours they had to restrain him and then
they sedated him shouts out to all my
people that work in ers y'all nurses the
doctors dude any I don't know how you do
it who encounter those scenarios you
know my best friend Mark he used to work
security at hospitals and he's working
night shifts he told me stories of [ __ ]
like that happened I don't know it's
[ __ ] gnarly man anyway we're we're
getting better but this whole last week
has been a complete blur for me because
we did twitchcon and we got home and
immediately got the sickest I've been in
a really long time yes same and but now
we're on our way to getting better and
dude ain't no sea sickness gonna stop us
now we at 20 mil whoa that was so weird
why do you have to do something please
I'll come back there no y-you stop
looking at me like that oh my god I'm
gonna leave it on it's cute it looks
like you're wearing uh put on you look
really cute Thanks Congrats I mean fun
to me don't touch bobby while he's
sleeping wrong you have to at least
touch like his head because he won't
jump if you pat him on his head cuz then
he you know what his by he thinks he's
getting it down yeah
like pat him on his head cuz then he
knows it's like you know he's been
really like giving me love lately I'll
just say that he's my dude he's such a
good boy I'm so proud of him but thank
you I appreciate you saying nice things
Oh
I'm not trying to say nice things to
make you happy I'm just telling the
truth and I'm genuinely proud of you and
as are a lot of other people so shouts
out to you guys for always you know
being super supportive and the best all
the time seriously I really appreciate
it thanks for treating me like a person
mm-hmm
and uh we obviously haven't really
talked about it but everyone at
twitchcon we met we really enjoyed
meeting and thank you guys for coming
out to support
I was so fun it was a fun year it was a
San Diego was so cool and wild and crazy
and um Mary Kish who hosted our Q&A was
wonderful you're so wonderful you know
why have you guys showed up man it was
cool it was it was cool I got to I got
to see the show floor for a little bit
you didn't but we saw our friends from
all over the world and it was cool it's
definitely special yeah I don't know
20ml bed man what I'm just like you know
what let me know no fun allowed I need
to just get unsick this is what I needed
yeah we're trying to hydrate we're
trying to drink so many liquids but then
it becomes like you have to pee all the
time and it's like kind of annoying at
least for me I don't know how that's
going for you I don't know where are the
liquids go sometimes you get sick and
you're just like you get to the sickest
point and then you start to get better
and then you just don't get all the way
better for like five six seven eight
days gonna be done with this that's what
I feel like right now yeah like I'm
functioning but it's just like that
annoying part that won't go away you
know
yeah well stupid anyway thank you guys
for hanging out with us for another week
yeah
thanks Bobby for being here who's now
finally sitting hot dog hot dog now he
looks like a taquito god he's so cute
we'll be back with another podcast next
week and
we'll be on twitch most of the week this
week and you know just continue to do
the thing look out for Jenna's NAT video
we'll see how that goes or just tell me
in this video not to post it and I won't
I genuinely think they want to see it I
think people want to see you day but
that's what people say until I post a
30-minute unedited nap and then
everyone's like I I didn't want to see
this I kind of lied people are gonna
like it guaranteed if it's allowed if
it's not allowed then they can just ban
it who cares
alright I post wedding videos that are
like the same is just like not posting
so like [ __ ] it you know sick yeah like
all the meme refuse is just like that
before it's the while it's in Final Cut
Pro it's copy straight
I haven't even uploaded it and it's
gotten flagged it is in Final Cut Pro
and it's getting currently flagged on
YouTube damn dude yeah well I'm while
I'm recording my not video it's
currently getting flagged
well it's in my brain right now I know
check your email it's copyrighted it's
it's they gave me a strike on my channel
two wallets in my brain all right on
that note I'll see you guys next week
have a wonderful week and good bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]